this morning on the dash two couples
sharing George's finest fruit where the
rest of the nation
Stephen row spent childhood summers on a
georgia peach farm and took the luscious
delicacy for granted that is until he
moved to Nashville and couldn't find
anything like the fruit he'd grown up
with so in 2012 he and his wife Jessica
started a business the peach truck
bringing ripe Georgia peaches first to
Tennessee and later to cities and towns
across the country now they also ship
their product nationwide and this summer
they published the peach truck cookbook
100 delicious recipes for all things
peach Jessica and Steven Rose good
morning and welcome to the dish thanks
you guys
I smell the peach eNOS and that's what
we have here these are all dishes from
the new cook yeah we're so we're so
excited to be sharing this table with
you guys this morning I'm gonna start
with the most important of the drinks
right a peach pisco sour which gets its
frothiness from an egg-white delicious
yo we've got a summer garden pasta salad
on the table and a stone fruit crostini
which is a great little appetizer for a
cocktail hour
sriracha shrimp skewers with a collard
green salad with peaches in it and a
burrata and Prosecco Peter a piece peach
salad sorry and then a caprese peach
salad and a blueberry and peach cobbler
is of course basically peaches yeah
there's a theme here what was it just
for you you grew up in Seattle so what
was it about the peach I mean peaches
are delicious yeah this was really like
a passion all of a sudden yeah
absolutely I mean Steven was my
boyfriend at the time when he took me
down to the farm and we're sitting on a
porch looking out at peach groves with
family friends and realize like I bit in
and I couldn't believe it like I mean
I'm from Seattle which there's great
fruit in Seattle
but there's something about a fresh
georgia peach that like I mean we've
seen that time and time again as we
started this business people biting in
saying I didn't know it could taste like
this and so yeah it was just from there
on I knew it wasn't just Stevens
nostalgia there was like really
something there
we're all missing out on yeah how do you
figure out I mean because you have to
incorporate it into every single dish
though so there's a lot of creativity
involved in that process there is for
sure this was an incredible process for
me to like see what the peach could do
and where it could go and really it's so
versatile I feel like it gets stuck in
the dessert category a lot but I have
found that I have loved it in the savory
dishes more than anything like that
pasta salad with that fresh peach taste
and it's got pine nuts it's it takes it
elevates just a simple summer pasta
salad to like a next level and I we did
it time and time again so it's it's
really been a wonderful book and we're
so excited to see it so Steven tell us
about the peach truck how did that idea
come about it really sounds remarkable
totally so we moved to Nashville in 2010
just a state away from where I grew up
and you know couldn't find a good peach
in Nashville go into farmers markets
grocery stores we just couldn't find
anything like what I grew up with so it
was a couple years later in 2012 we both
still had full-time jobs but we decided
to start bringing peaches from my
hometown to Nashville nights and weekend
selling them just to see if you know
really a night and weekend hobby but it
took off well enough that before the
next peach season we both quit our jobs
and said let's see if we can make a life
out of this and thankfully we've been
doing that ever since and first of all I
love that you still have the Georgia
accent Jessica were you actually like
smuggling the peaches out in your purse
originally before you got to this I was
Rihanna yeah yeah it's kind of
embarrassing but I'm also like I know a
good thing when I see it so I was like
hey I'm on the forint farm I had this
like big tote bag and I was just I mean
they said you're welcome to as many beds
as many it was a heavy bag leaving we're
gonna have you both of you you could
have this meal with anyone pastor
present who would it be oh wow I mean
for me I love a good laughs oh my boy
Jerry Seinfeld why not I'd go with the
25 man roster of the Atlanta Braves
thank you both we appreciate it
you know I'm for more on the roses and
the dish you can head to our website at
CBS this morning calm